well the mad lad actually did it faker
and t1 have made history by doing
something that no other team has managed
to do in the history of the lck a
perfect split
18 wins zero losses here's how it
happened
[Music]
all right as t1 have set a new record
we're kind of approaching a record
ourselves here at the score esports 2
million subscribers if you're not one of
that number then please consider
subscribing and like the video if you
enjoyed it bless you so the other week i
reported that t1 and faker have reached
an important milestone 15 wins and zero
losses breaking the previous record of
14-0 that was set by faker with skt1
back in 2015. so after faker broke his
own seven-year-old record the next
question was could he and t1 go one step
further and achieve the perfect split
the answer was of course they could now
nexus turrets will go down t1 an
absolutely historical moment 18-0 for
the first time in the lck and they tie
2015 summer skt and don juan 2020 summer
two teams that they went on to win
worlds at plus 29 points in the season
now have you been keeping up with the
lck over the past few months you'll know
this was no fluke t1 have looked like
absolute monsters this split only gen g
seemed to be even remotely in the same
league as them but of course they were
too owed by t1 just like everyone else
now just to clarify here the lck does
best of threes in its regular season
games t1 have technically lost
individual games while beating teams 2-1
in a best of three their match record is
perfect though so why is this all such a
big deal well to put it simply this
almost never happens fnatic did it once
way back in 2015 psg talon did it too
last summer in the pcs region in north
america teams like tsm cloud9 and
immortals have come incredibly close
with 17 and 1 splits but nobody has
achieved that perfect run the point is
it's rare now some people might say that
the best of three format in the lck
gives you a little bit of a safety net
because you can lose one individual game
and still take home the dub
but nah i don't think it's any less
impressive they still had to beat a team
twice to register a single win and they
did it against the best korean teams in
the world one asterisk for some people
though has been that the lck has been
hit hard by kovid we've seen a lot of
teams have to field substitutes because
one or more of their main roster are
sick this was the case with gen g t1's
only real competitor this split they had
to feel subs in both of their losses to
t1 and this has some people questioning
whether or not the perfect split would
have happened if they and other teams
were at full strength it's an important
detail to note but i don't think it
takes anything away from this incredible
achievement now faker naturally will get
a lot of attention for all of this and
there's a couple of reasons why firstly
for seven years it was his record that
was the highest bar to aim for in the
lck and now he's raised that bar to
basically perfection secondly it's faker
the unkillable demon king's story has at
times felt like it's being written by
anime writers who don't know the meaning
of the word subtlety faker is league's
goat but for the past five years he's
struggled to achieve the same kind of
glory as he did in the first half of his
career now of course when you win worlds
three times before your 21st birthday
that's an incredibly high bar to set for
yourself unfortunately the occasional
domestic successes he's had since have
never really compared to his
international ones now though there is
genuine talk of him and t1 going on to
make a serious run at worlds and that's
not just sentimental wishfulness there
is somewhat of a precedent for this this
team finished the split with a plus 29
game differential skt did that in 2015
dan 1 gaming did it in 2020 and both of
those teams then went on to win worlds
that year so things are potentially
looking more promising for faker on the
international stage now in a way they
haven't done for years but the question
is why now what is different well he's
usually found himself surrounded by top
talent over the years but this team is
something special every one of these
young players has the ability to carry
faker doesn't have to play perfectly
every game because each of these guys
has stepped up this year there's no dead
weight in this team zeus and owner are
solid as carrier is a genius of engaging
and my personal favorite is guma yushi
we could make a highlight reel just for
this kid the ad carry star broke an lck
record himself this split by racking up
219 kills in fact he's only the fourth
player in lck history to ever achieve
over 200 kills in a single split and
he's still only 20. it's been a weekend
of looking at the past our old records
being broken at how this team has come
together and at faker's nine-year career
so far but now people will rightly look
to the future and ask the next obvious
question how far can this team go they
still need to win playoffs to qualify
for msi they still need to do well in
summer to make it to worlds and if they
get there it ain't going to be a walk in
the park but people are starting to
whisper about them actually winning
worlds to do that it's going to take
something truly special but after a
record-breaking split like that i
wouldn't be surprised if they did
there's no dead weight in this team
there's no dead weight in this team zeus
and owner are solid as
there's no dead weight in this game
there's no dead weight in this team zeus
and owner are solid as
carrier is a genius of engaging